the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
we're waiting for people to come in what
are the important concepts this week
there was only the one lecture and the
lecture yesterday was pretty dense in
concepts let's build a build a quick
list here what who's got the first
offering okay that was a general overall
topic so how about a concept though okay
yep we introduced we introduced the
concept of the mass moment of inertia
matrix and I'll give it a context even
for example right H as I times Omega so
we introduced that didn't get very far
with it another one from yesterday
uh-uh yeah yeah so we talked about
rotation the subject yesterday was
really rigid body rotation about fixed
point on or off the body so here's our
axis of rotation called a and it's
spinning about that point at some Omega
but that point a could be over here too
and then the whole body is just going so
an example of rigid body rotation about
a point not on the body would be
something doing that okay no something
else
yes yeah what does it mean when H and
Omega may not align what's that what's
that mean so we got into that a bit
yesterday and anything else struck you
okay well that's a good that's a good
start let's just work with that now the
I want to I will do that second we're
actually going to come work a little bit
talking about the system in those
contexts but before I do that I want to
staff decided we hadn't done something
in lecture yet very carefully so that we
wanted to do it once carefully with in
recitation and that's a methodical way
of doing Freebody diagrams okay
so we have a system two masses springs
dashpots in the last class there were a
few people who didn't know really what
we meant by k's and seas and how they
work so may give you a quick definition
so here we have a spring it's got in
these are called linear spring so Hookes
law if you apply if you cause that
spring to move in Alcala here the plus X
direction you grab it and you pull on it
you have to apply force so the force to
pull that spring is positive KX in the
same direction as X but if that Springs
attached to a mass what direction is the
force that the spring applies on the
mass okay so I've given you a hint here
it pulls back right because this is
Newton's third law so we're doing
Freebody diagrams and we're concerned
with forces on the rigid bodies so this
spring if you put if this mass went that
way the spring would pull this way and
we'd indicate it the direction with an
arrow and its value as a KX dashpots are
similar except dashpots are activated by
velocity so this is a linear dashpot
such that it has a dashpot constant C
and if I give if I give this a positive
value of velocity the force required to
pull that dashpot is CX dot to the
linearly proportional velocity and the
force that if it
were attached to a mass that the dashpot
puts on the mash mass would be opposite
direction but same value CX dot but is
resisting the motion okay so we're going
to just give you a general method for
doing Freebody diagrams and the reason
we choose this problem is there's two
bodies and depending on you know which
is doing what the springs can this
intermediate spring in here particularly
can push or pull on either body and
getting the signs having methods so you
don't mess up the signs is what this is
all about so let's let's just start by
building a Freebody diagram of mass one
and I'm the assignment I'm going to give
you to work on just seat work here for a
minute
is only consider the springs for them
we'll just deal with the springs so
assume this system is moving you have to
do a Freebody diagram of it put the
spring forces on the on the mass and
your Freebody diagram so spend a minute
or so talk to your neighbors after you
get the little ways along with it and
I'm going to add is also on this whole
system external force f1 external force
F - that's your excitation but don't
don't worry about that for now let's
just figure out the spring forces and
I'll be quiet
I missed the step my apologies we should
have that we should do something else
first
the very first step is to assign the
coordinates wait let's all agree on the
coordinate system here so the question
really is the first thing you have to do
is you have to decide how many
independent coordinates you need to
completely describe the motion so how
many coordinates do you think are needed
for this problem I see a 1
that's a second one anybody else have a
suggestion so where would you put the
one but and measuring the displacement
of mass one okay and is that all we need
anybody have a firmer and it's
independent right they can move into how
many coordinates now do you think you
need Oh PCG change of mind it - two - no
and I've got them labeled up here for a
already all right so it's going to take
two and one of the ways you can test if
you have the right number is you know if
you think it's one assign it freeze it
is they're still independent movement of
part of the system if there is you have
yet another degree freedom if we freeze
both x1 and x2 - can anything move in
this system nope so we've got it nailed
down all right but where do you measure
there is something else you have to
determine and that is where do you make
zero yeah I also have to know that so
where is X zero in your picture for
we'll just talk about either one both of
X 1 and X 2 how would you pick the zero
point
Christina
okay she says when there's not exerting
force in either direction I would call
that the static equilibrium position
okay there is a there is a conceptual
problem with that which I'll will assume
that that will work if you've set the
system up so that there's no forces in
the springs but you know if I move this
wall in a little bit and let it reach
static equilibrium it has a static
equilibrium position all the springs
have forces in them now you pre compress
them so there's kind of a probability of
the conception you run it you can run
into a conceptual problem of that it
will still work picking the static
equilibrium position is a good thing to
do usually okay all right there are
other positions for example this system
it's a simpler system just ordinary
little mass spring but where do you make
0 when you pick your coordinate 0 spring
plus before the length of this so the
right now you're seeing the static
equilibrium position the spring has
tension in the weight of the mass right
so you could either make X right here
or the other obvious choice would be
I heard a couple voices I couldn't hear
what you said
well yeah but it turns out that actually
is a terrible choice because and then
you have to get involved with the length
of the story now like this spring
actually really doesn't enter into the
equation of motion unless you're really
silly about where you pick the measure
from static equilibrium is good but the
other one is a zero spring force
position is the other natural one to do
so that now at zero spring force that's
no extension of the spring because this
is preloaded when you do this and you
have to figure out what that does to you
okay again static equilibrium it has
some real advantages here but we'll talk
about that later
yeah I'm just saying there are actually
situations where there's zero there is
no zero spring force and yeah but
conceptually you then would two hadn't
ever thought about that for that could
be I could give you pause when you go to
solve the problem something that's pre
the springs are pre-loaded can you do or
your equations of motion valid so you
could if you pre-loaded this a little
bit squeezed it in this system has
natural frequencies right you agree with
that this is very similar to to this
system but except it's just now doesn't
happen to have a third spring and have
gravity involved but this just has two
natural frequencies that one and one
that's a little harder for me to do but
that one okay so if I pre-loaded this a
little bit squeezed it in some with the
natural frequencies change yes how many
think yes get your hands up come on
you're gamblers how many think yes how
do you think no how many are just don't
want to raise your hand like you
okay the natural frequency doesn't
change it turns out the preload doesn't
matter in the linear in a linear system
like this but so there's some nuances in
here that they're the simple system like
this has some little traps in it that it
will take them time to learn your way
through but let's keep it simple
no preload the static equilibrium
position find for other free by today
I'm for mass one Springs only only deal
with the springs take a couple minutes
and talk to your neighbor if you need to
and okay so I won't come look at each of
your things I want to have you different
groups kind of what this should take one
force at a time so you guys give me a
spring give me a force on this mass due
to its prey give me a spring force and
tell me what direction it's in so tell
me which spring we're talking about all
right
so is this being compressed no this is
static equal in position but we want it
now if you give it an initial I can let
go it's going to sit there and do
something we want to we're trying to
derive the equations of motion and to do
so we have to start with a free body
diagram so it's moving and there are
forces on it caused by Springs and by
dashpots and by the external forces so
right now we're going to do Freebody
diagram but only the components due to
the spring Springs so tell me where what
happens what does that spring how does
this spring appear in that on that
Freebody diagram
okay four so what's this thing on which
directions I don't understand if I yell
wish okay well that's kind of the point
of the exercise when I expand I expect
many of you to have some confusion about
what direction to go because you don't
have a simple you don't have a standard
method by which you approach this okay
so which displacement though this system
has two possible displacements
okay so if you said if you move it a
positive x1 then you will get a spring
force the spring one does what opposes
and what's it value K 1 X 1 so that's
what a motion X 1 causes with that's a
result with spring 1 what's the result
of spring two if you have a motion X 1
same is gonna be pressure forces also
right it's trying to squeeze that spring
down it's pushing back right so you're
also going to get a spring K 2 X 1 right
now are there any other forces that
result from the motion of that body in
the springs just spring forces there
from that yeah I'm at body by itself no
but is that all of the spring forces no
so now what if you let body to move and
on now I'm going to give you a little
rubric a little way to go about this we
start by assigning our coordinates then
you you specify positive X 1 X 1 dot X 2
X 2 dot one at a time
and from that you deduce the direction
of the forces of the resulting forces
okay so if that what we've done there is
consistent with it a positive value of x
one spring one pulls back k 1 x 1 spring
2 pushes back K 1 X 1 and that's the
rillette the end of spring forces due to
X 1 so now you let just let's say okay
let X 1 be 0 for a moment and now let
there be a positive X 2 does that cause
any spring force on mass 1 what do you
think that one a positive X 2 puts
tension in the spring pulls it in that
direction so now you're going to get a K
2 X to any other spring forces caused by
motion of 2 it's the only connecting
spring right so that those are the
spring forces on mass 1 now let's move
on to dashpot forces and you do exactly
the same thing assume a positive value
of x 1 dot what is it cause in dashpot
forces what's the first dashpot do when
you pull positive x 1 dot in that
direction resists or not - Potts resist
so it's going to be in the minus
direction and a value how big
so now you get dashpot forces c1 x1 dot
and u how about the c2 - pot same thing
c2 x2 x1 dot okay and that's the only
dashpot forces caused by a velocity of
mass 1 so now say let that be zero and
cause velocity at the other places and
find out if anything happens so now let
X 2 dot be positive what do we put on
Freebody diagram go in which direction
positive and what value all right and
it's our free body diagram complete yeah
and yeah and now it's complete all the
forces in the system it's there it's
constrained in this direction so we just
know N equals mg there's no motion
allowed so we get no equation of motion
in that direction we're going to get one
equation of motion for this mass and ham
and one more equation of motion for the
second the number of equation of motions
equal the number of independent
coordinates and we found two independent
coordinates we get two equations of
motion so take this and write down the
equation of motion for mass one sort it
out yeah Betsy
okay so let's see if we can do something
here so this is my this is second Mass
this is a first mass actually better
here's the wall and the first mass so x1
is in that direction right so I pull
that way the spring does pulls back on
the mass that's obvious to you right and
on the other side if this is mass one
now and you have a second spring over
here the second mass over here and
spring in between them if you put a
positive motion of mass one this spring
pushes back okay so that counts for the
minus direction of K 2 x1 then if the
second mass moves in that direction here
you move it here the second mass there's
a tension in this am i pulling back to
resist you or or not
what is this spring doing them with my
hand it's pulling that way on it K 2 x2
okay so that's our free body diagram
right right out of the equation of
motion for that system
give you a little reminder that's how
you ought to begin right
and if you're done do it do the same
thing for the second mask well the
others are working on the first one draw
free body diagram of mass two and write
down the equation of motion which one
the bottom C 2 X 2 da all right so let's
build this
so the I'm just going to go I'm just
going to talk through it rather than
have you help me build this I now did
sum of the external forces that's what
all of the external forces and only the
external horses should show up on that
diagram the mass times the acceleration
is the sum of the external forces so
every arrow on that diagram ought to
appear over here in the direction of
whichever this equation is so this is
the equation that has to do with the
motion to mass 1 and I look over here
and I see ok I'm just going to go top to
bottom minus K 1 X 1 minus K 2 X 1 and
the minuses are coming from the
directions of the arrows minus C 1 X 1
dot and then I have a plus K 2 X 2 plus
C 2 X 2 dot plus F 1 then I miss one
zero I miss the see I miss this guy
right minus C 2 X 1 dot ok so the arrows
tell me the signs and all of the all of
the forces are there they just all add
up over here on this side and I've gone
ahead and drawn what I think is the
right thing from s 2 so now the but you
do the same system you go to mass 2 and
you say ok positive deflection of mass 1
what is the spring force the results
well it pushes
on it positive velocity of mass 1 the
stash pot pushes on it positive
deflection of mass 2 2 springs pushback
positive velocity of mass 2 1 dash pot
resists and you have an external force
and you could write this one down just
let you just add up all those forces em
and now you have a second equation m2 x2
double dot equals and you add it up okay
so get I want to do one other thing I'm
going to ask you a question get you to
raise your hands let everybody to try
the raise your hands okay
could you take assume that I had written
out that second equation and normally
actually let me take one more step
normally what we would do is to rewrite
this in sort of a standard form is to
move all the motion variables to one
side and all the actual exciting forces
to the other and so we'd say m1 x1
double dot plus and then normally you
put in the X dot terms next so we have a
c1 plus c2 X 1 dot minus c2 X 2 dot plus
now i get my K terms K 1 plus K 2 X 1
minus K 2 X 2 equals f1 ok and that's
kind of standard form now and I could
write I get a second equation from the
second one that would look like that now
once you get it in this sort of standard
form could you and you remember how if
you've ever even ever had linear algebra
write this in matrix form
so how many of you feel comfortable you
get to sit down and write this out in
matrix form go on and how many you think
it might be a bit of a challenge okay
means how many would you like me is how
many of you like me to show you what it
looks like in matrix form and give you
the answer so most of you okay I'll take
the time to do that and it's not let's
see did I write it out already
oh look at that Bing ding ding ding so
remember the way you need to know all
you need to know in this course about
vectors and matrices is how to multiply
a vector times a matrix so here's an
acceleration vector here's the mass
matrix and you take these two elements
my two fingers here and multiply them by
those you go like this to that so x1
double dot times M 1 double dot gives
you the this term right and you get no M
2 x2 double dot because it's a zero in
the matrix in the second in that second
position so there's no it get no x2
double dot term and that's correct
same thing with you here's the x2 x1
here's this damping matrix this is the
stiffness matrix and so if you just did
these multiplies you'd get back to
equations the ones we just derived so
you need to know how to do this kind of
thing because we write that H equals I
Omega and our Omega is has three
components Omega X Omega Y and Omega Z
and you need to do be able to do that
manipulation alright we got a little bit
time left guys I wanted to do one little
exercise that had to do more with us
with this sort of thing to kind of
reinforce a bit what we did yesterday
and that would be so unlike any final
questions about this yeah
Oh solving it it's not we don't do I
used to teach I taught for about 20
years of course called mechanical
vibration I just don't have time to
teach it anymore and that's what you do
in there or in 1803 803 you do a little
bit of it so this system would have as
two degrees of freedom it has two
natural frequencies two mode shapes to
go with it so this system vibrates as
you and it's not real hard to solve but
you would assume for initially if you
want to know natural frequencies you set
the forces to zero is that the damping
to zero initially and you just assume a
solution of the form that x1 of T and x2
of T equals some unknown constants
cosine Omega T just plug it in you just
plug that in you'll end up with a
algebraic equation and the algebraic
equation actually has eigenvalues and
you find the two eigenvalues on there
the two natural frequencies all right I
want to do something with angular stuff
so here's my system that we were playing
with the beginning of class and in this
form it's nice and balanced so this is
just to reinforce a couple things that I
was just beginning to teach you
yesterday this is a rigid body it's
rotating I attached to it a rotating
frame at a in the X Direction is y and z
so Y is into the board okay and that
frame rotates with my system and the
rotation rate of the system is Omega and
it's K in the rotating system which
happens to line up with big K with the
stationary system but that's my rope
this is my Omega vector here is zero
zero Omega this is the Z
of the rotation okay now what is let's
first start with this what is p1 and of
a linear momentum of that mass in the
system and we've done this Robin a lot
of times so what directions it in and
momentum is MV right so what's the
velocity of the mass it's caused by
rotation and only rotation no P just P
linear momentum at and it's in got a B
and O right I mean reference to the O
frame but it can use unit vectors in
this rate go with D 1 J hat and how big
right here on Omega time what so this
this system I guess I need to give you
I'm going to call the position this
position this is x1 z1 it says this
coordinate is x1 z1
so if I give you that information what's
the velocity of that point Omega X 1 J
hat
into the board right now wait it's
spinning into the board yeah
how to be in the J direction yeah it
ought to be an R Omega and it has an M
associated with it
the what's P - coming out of the board
at all right okay
and those little J the J hats are in the
rotating coordinate system where I want
them
so what's h1 its r1 with respect to what
now I got it so you can't do angular
momentum without picking a got to pick
the point so this is why we choose we
choose the coordinates the reference
frame we're going to use to give us some
information that we want I want to know
the torques about this point so I'm
going to put my a here could have put it
any place the long is the axis of
rotation passed through it so this one
is our one cross r1 with respect to a
cross p1 so what is r1 in this system
X 1 I 1 K cross with m1 Omega X 1 J
alright and let's sort this work that
one out
so we have an eye x ej k and so I get a
m1 x1 squared Omega K and then I do this
term times that I get a K cross J minus
I and I get m1 x1 z1 Omega I hat all
right all right
and so this actually technically this is
my little H this is little h2 and if I
let M 1 equal m to here my total H for
this system pardon
oh whoops how'd I do that and I'd moved
on to h2 yet sorry about that
this is still h1 okay and it's that so
what's H what's h2 how's it differ it's
kind of look here it only differs in one
word one respect yeah you get a minus a
negative X here when you go to carry out
the multiplication so now the I cross J
term gives you a yeah you're absolutely
right so you get you had to put a minus
X here and you won't have to multiply it
by this one so the IJ term you get minus
times a minus I times J is a positive K
you end up with m2 x1 squared Omega K
the same direction each component and
what happens here
okay and so they they have the second
term that I term is opposite direction
and if m1 equals m2 and you added these
two together what happened those last
two terms they cancel right okay so if
this is true the sum of these two H with
respect to a is just 2 M x1 squared
Omega K all right so if you took in this
first in the first system if these two
weren't equal they didn't cancel out if
you go through and take dhdt you take
the time derivative of these terms then
you get a Omega K and over here you get
an Omega dot term and then you get a DI
DT term all that yet but you will end up
with values of dhdt that are not in the
K direction you agree for sure
and those hat are associated with real
torques in the system that happen when
this is true that Newson that difficult
term out here cancels out and you're
left only with the K term and when you
take this time derivative you only get
you know dhdt you get a theta dot or
Omega dot and that says that H is in it
that says the torque is in what
direction one there the end when you get
just this 4-h what is the direction of
the DHD key still in k so the torque is
aligned with the spin H is aligned with
the spin they're all aligned and the
system is actually beautifully balanced
there's no you don't feel any torques
around your where you're holding it down
here at day all right but if I took one
of these off kind of back to that one
arm system there's two
it's terribly unbalanced so the moral of
the story here is well is if I don't
want to have these unwanted torques what
can you say about the desired mass
distribution in the system I hear a vote
for symmetry okay and that's that's the
general rule if your masses are
distributed symmetrically about the axis
of spin no off axis torques
yeah it's symmetric symmetry means they
better be the same size - not just in
the same place if once twice as big as
the other no go right I put a second
mass on one of those arms system is back
to being unbalanced so anytime anytime
this H vector the total H of the system
is not lined up with the spin the system
has an asymmetry in it and the system
will have it will require additional
torques just to hold it in place when
it's spinning so when you have these
additional torques that come from being
a being asymmetric that the system is
called is said to be dynamically
imbalanced so if you pick up a stone a
big stone in your car wheel or a block
hunk of mud or ice it frozen on the rim
you're going down the road what's it
feel like you ever had an unbalanced
tire in a car all right
where have you guys lived an unbalanced
tire around a car you're going down the
road you know right that's what this is
all about you have a case of imbalance
so we doing two a couple more minutes so
imbalance comes from having angular
momentum that's not pointed in the same
direction as
Nega memnon pointed in the same
directions angle of spin is evidence of
unbalanced and you can calculate how bad
the imbalances by doing D HDD and
actually finding out how much torque is
being applied to the system that
ordinarily the bearings wouldn't have to
resist but this thing has overturning
torques that are trying to make it
wobble back and forth on you so if let's
one little one last exercise which is
actually a quite important point if I
moved a up here right on the line
between these two things so this is a
and now this is X and this is Z the
coordinates of this point become what X
1 and 0 and if you go this all these
equations still apply so if I just move
my coordinate system so the X's are the
same the Z's go to 0 what do you end up
with four terms what happens to this
thing that goes to zero goes away and
you only get this term and so by simply
moving a 2 here my angular momentum
vector now lines up with the spin kind
of weird does the imbalance still exist
with your cars to be doing this down the
road just because you chose to look at
it from a different point of view you
have and car still unhappy so this this
kind of inconsistency here sort of
what's the problem or maybe not a
problem but you choose
to put a when you're computing angular
momentum you can choose where you put
this point to give you the information
you're after and in this case if I were
designing the system and I wanted to
know the bending moment in these bars
sticking down here I put a here because
it will give me the torques with respect
to this point these these torques down
here still exist it's just as if you put
your point at which you compute angular
momentum up here you won't be able to
find them
you can't compute it because you've
reduced the moment arm to zero this
moment arm and you just won't get that
torque okay all right I've run out of
time but will they'll be more on this
subject Thanks